there are there are a rash of shootings
that have been happening uh school
shootings
and one of my biggest disappointments
or is that all of these shootings are
done primarily by
men and it feels like it's another
thing that women have been kept out of
like you know stem
is there is there a way that's a
terrible joke
it is a terrible joke but you know it's
true
and so why are so many men
being driven to violence
well it's not so many i mean the school
shooters are a
tiny tiny infinite infinitesimal
percentage of the population
and so it's very difficult to formulate
a policy to deal with such things
because they are
in fact so rare and so unpredictable
there's i mean aggression per se is
has its uses males are
disproportionately violent compared to
females or at least with regards to
physical violence
females have their own particular brand
of aggression which
has more to do with reputation
destruction than physical
violence and that starts very early yes
you can detect that in children
um so
and you have a very very large country
right 330 million people
the it doesn't you know one person in a
million is pretty seriously disturbed
and so that's a shooting a day if it's
one person in a million
and you don't have a shooting a day so
it's less than one in a million so
that's very very rare
and thank god for that it is it is when
you look at the numbers like that but it
does
feel uh it's too much right i mean i'm
sure that like you know
when we look at across the world at
other countries that don't have these
things
is any of this attributable to the fact
that men
now and women as well too but since
we're on the topic of men
are retreating more into the digital
world uh
that they are less socialized that they
are more
into you know potential potentially uh
not to blame video games but like
people seem to be retreating from the
types of
um social structures that men had
participated in for years which was
marriage
family uh you know owning property
things like that
um and it seems like a lot of men are
not doing those things or doing those
things much later in life
and there seems to be and you've
addressed this i think as effectively as
anyone
there seems to be a tendency of those
men uh that are not
participating in those social structures
to feel
alienated and and uh disenfranchised and
that often leads to
you know negative pathologies how do you
encourage
the type of social commitments that
um point men in the right direction
um and i think you're a big proponent of
the
you know more traditional way of life
where it's you know
forming a bond with someone getting
married
um trying to you know uh
you know create manifest the life you
want that's a lot of the things you've
read and you've talked about
involved that um do you see the digital
spheres being a real problem
here because people can escape into that
i don't see the digital sphere as a
as a problem um not as such uh
i think pornography might be a problem
that's the digital sphere
well fair enough but you'd have to
decompose the digital sphere into its
various aspects and then look at
each of them as i said i think that the
the
ease of access of pornography and its
proliferation i think that's
not a good thing i think there are many
good things about the digital sphere
i mean there are large communities of
encouragement
that have popped up on youtube
i i suppose i am at the head of one but
there are many people doing similar
things like jocko willink is a good
example and
um and your your question was
i guess two part you commented that
there's perhaps a disproportionate
number of people who are feeling
alienated
from the general community from life
itself from the social world from
the natural world for that matter and
that that alienated
isolated and lonely existence can lead
to bitterness and
and god only knows where that goes right
that can move in an aggressive direction
quite quickly well the antidote to that
as far as i'm concerned is
something like encouragement is partly
why i'm so appalled by the
characterization of our
society as a to essentially as it both
symbolically and
and literally as a tyrannical patriarchy
you know that the criticism that emerges
on the left is essentially
that hierarchies are predicated on
power and and
power is equated to tyranny and and then
so social structure itself is equated to
tyranny and
that's nonsensical it's a nonsensical
oversimplification
the fundamental ruling principle
of a functioning hierarchy is not power
it's something more like fatherhood
[Music]
it's something more like encouragement
and reciprocity and
like and and what reciprocity
and courage and productivity and
generosity all of those things and
i was talking to jocko willing a couple
of weeks ago and
and he's a very assertive and
man very much capable of physical
aggression built for it and
both physically and temperamentally and
he went through the naval seal training
and
that's a prime example of a patriarchal
hierarchy let's say
sure but what they were taught most
fundamentally was that
each of them had their buddies back
right like they were taught reciprocity
right